nous vous en parlions hier la machine
politique est enclenché la préfecture
d'indre-et-loire a dévoilé la liste
officielle des candidats aux élections
départementales 19 cantons que se
partageront l'union de la droite et du
centre la gauche l'extrême droite et la
république en marche en 2015 c'est la
droite qui l'emportait plaçant
jean-gérard paumier à la tête de
l'exécutif
dans un mois les cartes seront rebattues
le détail avec samuel colin au pouvoir
depuis 2000 15 l'union de la droite et
du centre
aux dernières élections sur les 19
cantons du département 15 sont
remportées par l'actuelle majorité 21 de
ses membres se représente dont le
président sortant prêt à défendre son
bilan auprès de ses électeurs
il n'y a pas eu d'augmentation de taux
d'imposition pendant pendant six ans il
n'y a pas eu de vote contre le budget de
perse à de la minorité pendant six ans
et tous les grands projets on les a voté
ensemble donc je pense qu'on a une
gouvernance apaisée
il ya aussi un projet important solide
avec je dirais une majorité qui était
prête je dirais à poursuivre une action
mais en six ans le paysage politique
n'est plus le même
les dernières élections municipales
apportent leur lot de changements la
gauche menée par les écologistes emporte
la ville de tours face justement à une
majorité alors de droite et du centre le
pari est donc aujourd'hui d'élargir et
de poursuivre sur la même dynamique
dix sept cantons sous la bannière appelé
la touraine en commun dont un binôme à
tours nord vous aurez partout sur le
département à la fois des visages connus
à la fois des visages associatif non
encarté à la fois des personnes
encartées dans des mouvements et les
partis politiques de la gauche et des
écologistes ils faut
aujourd'hui renforcer les moyens du
département pour suivre et surtout
permettre aux gens d'accéder à leurs
droits autres forces en présence le
rassemblement national
aucun élu aujourd'hui à l'hôtel du
département mais un parti présent dans
13 cantons pour ces élections
la république en marche elle se contente
de deux binômes dont un à tours-nord
canton le plus disputé du département
avec cette candidature
avoir décidé de mettre des deux hommes
est des candidats la dca match là où
nous avions nous avons des possibilités
peut-être ces élections le département
gère 600 millions d'euros de budget
chaque année dont une grande partie
consacré au social avec notamment le
revenu de solidarité active